[Music]
in creepy hubby News creepy huh that's
all people think I'm not creepy hubby
but I'm not true
you're creepy dad Oh fine daddy
submitted by a rock of the boat baby
rock I like a ball motor reveals her
horror at finding naked photos of her
husband took of her as she slept
why I'd be flattered if it's my husband
I do think it's a little wave it's a
little bit strange why was your husband
though while sleeping does a nice resume
on no I wouldn't say by I'm creeped out
like what the [ __ ] more like that's odd
it's more it's just like guys for me if
you're married you could take picture if
they're [ __ ] in the shower like you
own each other that's that's what my
daughter you know maybe it's like if I
know about it but all right cool
whatever but if it's just like you're
fine one day just felt like I'll be
found it I just like it's in the secret
file so I still don't think that's weird
but you're hiding it but also what's
your thinking about pictures let's say
you open a drawer and there's all these
romantic letters of journals of daily
journals are all gee I mean that's not
against your consent
they're like without her consent you
don't need [ __ ] consent or it doesn't
affect her yeah it doesn't involve her
does in fact it's just you writing your
own thing about her let's take pictures
of my dog sleeping
oh he prays doesn't like there's no
caller that makes a Centon that makes a
big difference no caller you're naked
you Adam Wolfe is it my definition
emerged you're one person now there's no
such thing as consent yeah I agree
doesn't make it not creepy I don't have
a choice how much [ __ ] you guys know
that like he puts all this like if she
just reached in my bank account and took
out like 20 G's I'm like all right
that's my wife yeah I'm good [ __ ]
you should do that you didn't know you
had that privilege huh I agree if I take
her car just [ __ ] crashed it it's
like yeah so what I agree that it maybe
is not a right from wrong but it could
be like a kind of weird thing creepy
what because you keep saying consent I
agree consent you do you do you but if I
came home yeah and I'm gonna go to sleep
and often her brother's laying in the
bed too I can alert you like hey my
brother's gonna sleep or time okay cool
[Laughter]
yeah I don't know what about murders
somebody that geo murder somebody it
just must be back you up yeah if I
murder someone she'd better back me up a
lot of waiting that one's like that
wouldn't I agree she can't testify
against your something yeah
spouses kid you can't force a spouse to
specify what one person no it's not the
act of taking the photos weird it's just
but if it was just the secret that's
weird that's the word that I'm like but
what if the secret is its kind of harm I
feel like this is a harmless why have a
secret though what if what if I have a
secret of taking pictures of bananas I
just love it and then you never knew I
have this bundle okay but it's a little
weird I want to know every legal though
like taking photos without someone's
consent even a white evil we've been
away is it yeah it could be married
bless your wife there's no skin there's
no consent I don't feel like [ __ ]
because you could rape your wife
breaking the law you can write none of
my marriage in my definition of marriage
if she wants to [ __ ] me she could [ __ ]
me if I'm a [ __ ] like a [ __ ] and if I
don't want to [ __ ] we don't [ __ ] it just
we just gotta rest a little bit first I
we [ __ ] while she's sleeping
[Laughter]
jokes aside rape is not cool
we're totally kidding if such that you
even have to say that it does but people
are gonna be like and shea ruins the
joke when you have to put a disclaimer
on everyone but you know before I said
that disclaimer there was already like
40 [ __ ] people going like you know
rape is mono Joe no and we agree
Joe's banana pictures I I do think the
banana pictures is kind of similar to
this we're like I wouldn't like judge
Joe but I think like bullets bro it's
kind of its kind of weird but you do you
yeah same think of all that happened Ben
jiu-jitsu I think weird but cool do you
the thing I think when you're taking
pictures of a sleeping stranger yeah
there's no rapport there's no friend
there's nothing yeah there's nothing
there so it's kind of like what the [ __ ]
yeah people are mad about my video on
Instagram of the guys sleeping on the
plane I saw that no I was on a plane and
heading to Japan there's like this
business guy that was like across the
aisle and he was just like falling
asleep so I took a video of him like
sideways came to see his whole face
that's [ __ ] up I can't do that he's
like Marlon sleep when the moment he
goes I said hi I got night I don't have
too much good like he was like that's so
[ __ ] rude like I'm like you didn't
get his consent that's quite proud of
that oh there are states I don't know if
it's California I think it's where you
uh maybe taking pictures of people is
illegal yeah we're lucky if you're
vlogging in their back like technically
it's like a so let's say we have a lot
of friends who are professional
photographers and now they get us in
candid times and just like we're just
chilling talking and then I'm like [ __ ]
thanks for taking that picture man and
then you sue the map dog yeah yeah or
what I was like someone who just likes
photography and then he goes takes
photos and there's people in the photo
and then everyone sees him you know I
can understand if I didn't like look at
this [ __ ] ugly ass [ __ ] for
whatever was she pointing at me
I've seen that I've seen people that
just walk around downtown with the
camera and they take pictures of
buildings people birds that's a huge
category of photography yeah one of
people I don't think you offended I
don't feel like I don't feel like don't
some people I'll be like posing and he's
like you ruined the shot man it's
supposed to be like [ __ ] natural can
you get out of my picture no sir hit
start stop the [ __ ] oh I don't want no
consent me and [ __ ]
violation of eyes yeah so this one she
posted on this like parent blog forum
type website called Mumsnet
and this is what she wrote married for
ten years with two young daughters under
four dear husband is a fantastic dad
caring husband and we are very happy
that was until Monday when I found naked
pictures of myself that he had taken
when I was asleep or not looking without
consent and emailed them to himself from
his phone I am so upset and spent last
night crying myself to sleep for right I
don't know what to do I'm not sure
foursome was the only way I'm not sure I
will ever be able to trust him again but
I also don't want to break up break my
family up as until now we have been very
happy Wow what should I do
well I mean how many kids do so they
thought [ __ ] did they just did he just
pull out a zipper and like pull it out
and like how to play basketball jizz
into her vagina no here's the thing so I
can oh I can still I understand this cuz
there is a thing called revenge porn
there's a girl that I know that also
he's stockpiling he could made her on it
use it against her because there's a
girl that I know that [ __ ] over a lot
of dudes that I know and one of them
took a photo of her sleeping naked and
it got like sent around to the point
where I got it Your Honor I mean so even
if it was taken while they were dating
but and then at that time she trusted my
loss [ __ ] does happen and he can use it
against her cuz you don't know the
intentions yeah exactly so I can
understand why I think it's the trust
secret thing exactly I think the main
thing here so let me finish what she
said so she said what
- I confronted him and he has been very
upset and apologized repeatedly and is
begging for another chance he said it
was a huge mistake but I have found a
photo dating back to 2015 so I think
this has been going on for a while I
feel totally sick and betrayed but I
don't know if I'm overreacting by being
so upset what would you do if you
apologized I'm not a lady so it's
difficult for me to understand because
if just took pictures of me sleeping I'd
be like I never knew you liked me like
that like you always call me fat in a
day I didn't know you thought you were
getting horny over me like what do you
do with these pictures like tell me tell
me you know what I've just took a photo
of you and you're sleeping your dicks
off this book and then she took it to my
soft as [ __ ] it's gonna be soft kiss I'm
not gonna be hard sleeping and then like
when you guys break up she's like man
[ __ ] Joe and she uploaded then
everyone's like Joe has a small dick so
Joe there's just gonna be comma they've
been married for 10 years I'm not I'm
not really worried about it being leaked
I think for me I'm more so like okay so
if this is a secret is it is it like a
fetish like you want me to not know and
you get turned on by this this this
thing or like what's going on you know
like well I agree I I would approach it
that way too I don't know I mean I am a
girl and I don't know how I feel about
it yet cuz I'm trying really hard to
empathize with her but then it's also
hard for me to do that because I feel
like I would probably ask a ton of
questions kind of like is it are you
keeping it a secret because it's a
fetish like how long has it been
happening and I feel like with his
responses if he continues to lie more
and more more than I'm like oh this is
weird like I don't know who the [ __ ] I'm
married to it's like yeah but if he's
completely open and starting like now we
have that open line of communication of
whatever his [ __ ] fetishes and I'm
like alright cool we just got that much
closer I think if you just open about it
it's less weird just don't be [ __ ]
weird in the hydeia like for me I
understand the revenge porn part of it
if they're dating so like for me it's
like when you're dating everyone has
regards up right like what are they
worth trying to do they just want to
hear it and quit it or like what are we
trying to get out with this but then the
minute you marry you guys are agreeing
to put your guards completely down in
all aspects of your life so once you
agree to do that
if there were these secret photos that
surfaced revenge porn or stockpiling to
backstab me later on is the last thing
that I'm considering yeah I think like
marriages looked at different now
probably going to be like people see it
like that I do I see you like that but I
don't think the world doesn't see it
like it's dating not dating but in this
people still have their personal
thoughts yeah that are very reserved not
a lot of people open up their [ __ ] to
the world like we do oh yeah I tell just
everything she tells me if we just don't
have that like well you know if anything
we should have we should have a little
bit more of that where we're like maybe
we shouldn't tell that to each other you
mean like a so like when these things
happen this is why it's so weird to us
it's like why are those strangers you
know like why is it so taboo to talk
about you have ten years of relationship
you have two kids at that point it's
like you should be not ashamed of
anything I don't think that school of
thought is new because even like my
mom's generation and she grew up like
one was it like the fit so she was born
in the 50s like they would even advise
me to be like hey I have your secret
bank account just in case anything
happened so there's still that life
we're just disconnected yeah because the
thing is we're not we don't watch our
backs around people like here that we
trust
I could tell Bartlett hey uh I like
sleep [ __ ] he's not gonna be like oh
I thought you I thought I knew you Joe
yeah [ __ ] bastard like what like you
sleep [ __ ] your girlfriend my best
friend abyss do you get consent well if
I'm trying to log into like my bank
account and Joe's around I don't have to
go like these are the people I trust
yeah you know like I don't know weird
yeah everyone does but it is a violation
of trust though if he's doing something
behind her back and it's making her
uncomfortable and and she's like I
thought I known you for 10 years and you
take a pictures of me
yeah cuz we don't know her history
either like what if she's a victim of
like rape or something where she she's
very she's a porn star
via obviously warehouse it's about
personal vulnerability and sexual stuff
that's basically like the one thing that
people have to hold on to a lot of
people were saying like I'm so sorry
this happened to you like you might even
want to get the police involved and
they're saying also that these type of
images like people sleeping or photos
taken of people behind their backs like
their share their highly shared and
requested on a lot of sites oh he's
making money oh so what if he's a part
of like a sleep group we're commenting
it's like the fact that he emailed them
to himself that right there tells like a
lot of people were speculating that it
tells a lot yeah did not keep those
images to himself why would he email if
that's the weird part because you just
saving your camera yeah yeah I mean just
upload it to your laptop though keep it
there oh I see but then there's other
people also commenting saying like I
personally wouldn't have a problem with
this like you know you should just
discuss it with them let him know that
you're uncomfortable with it but I don't
think I would make it a big deal as big
as you all right so everyone has their
own opinions on I think it's like if my
face wasn't showing earlier or whatever
how many titties are showing is it just
one or like there's like recognizable
tattoos also yeah I think everyone has
their boundaries and moral content
threshold so like this might be to her
as bad as like her husband been cheating
or whatever yeah what Street is a double
life actually hands on the person yeah
some wives are cool with my husband's
been murdering it's okay
that's true what a good wife
[Music]
[Music]